let me just remind the women out there  any any female athletes who are  listening to this there is power in  numbers always so it may be terrifying  for you to speak out on your own it  becomes much less terrifying when there  are many people involved and i say this  you know um audience knows i say this  about every issue  that even you know during covet times i  was advocating for businesses to speak  up and saying you have to kind of speak  up together it can't just be one  business it has to be businesses at  large so if you're out there and you're  worried about speaking up the answer may  be to solidify a group of women um who  are valuable who have trained  extensively and speak out together  because that always makes a bigger mark  and it becomes much harder  to penalize people when they're standing  firm together on an issue